you know one of the things I got
questions about last night in the
backstage VIP Q&A section was Dave what
about real estate I had a young men 24
years old thinking about selling the
house he had already bought it 24 Wow
it's a great start in life and it you
know real estate always comes up because
we all have this desire to own our home
that's not a uniquely American thing
it's a kind of a human nature thing we
want to stabilize the nest where the
chicks are going to grow up into eaglets
and where they will spread their wings
and if we do it right they will leave
yeah home home but we've gotten so
obsessed with homeownership because it's
become a good part of you know doing
your life financially right is owning
your home over a long period of time but
people get in such a hurry and they do
it out of order and they do it when they
can't afford it and they sell wrong when
they buy wrong and real estate is the
largest transaction most people make and
too many times they do it in such a way
that it brings more curses than
blessings to their lives give you an
example young couple 25 years old just
got married 24 years old just got
married got $30,000 in student loan debt
to car notes and every body who is broke
everybody who was broke is tell them you
got to buy a house I mean you just
started off you got your cars you got
your student loan it's time to buy a
house buy house my house my house my
house my house you got to buy a house
and you know what that's stupid that
house is not gonna be a blessing in that
situation it's gonna be a curse
homeownership is a wonderful thing when
you do it right when you do it wrong
it's one of the dumbest things you can
do because it's got zeros on the end of
your dumb you know renting for a year or
two gives you time to get on your feet
you get settled in the new city you get
rid of your debt all of it you build
your merge
see phone you build your down payment
then you're ready to buy and I don't
yell at you for a mortgage
I don't borrow money for anything I do
not believe in borrowing money because
it has so much downside and so little
upside lots of people see it as a way to
get what they want when they want it but
I'm telling you it's a bad idea but if
you're the only thing I don't yell at
people for borrowing money on this show
I'll just call you straight-up stupid
for a car payment okay I'm gonna call
you stupid for a credit card payment but
you know I don't yell at you for getting
a home on a mortgage but turn around
let's get it paid off and take a 15-year
fixed-rate where the payments are no
more than 1/4 of your take-home pay
that's the thing you got to do there
when you get ready to put your home on
the market for goodness sakes get a
professional involved a monkey can sell
a house in this market
houses sold I mean a monkey can sell a
house in this market it doesn't require
any particular pizzazz to sell a house
in a market that's you know we had one
of our al P's the other day they put the
house on the market for two hundred and
sixty thousand they got eighteen offers
and forty-eight hours of sold for older
over three hundred and five thousand
dollars in a market like that a monkey
can sell a house but that really wasn't
a house sale that was an auction and you
gotta have somebody knows what they're
doing to stay on top of a market that's
that hot and help you get the most out
of your house you get ready to buy a
house in a market where you got you're
competing with multiple other offers you
actually want to become the buyer that
buys the house not just somebody who
puts in a bunch of bids and stands on
the sidelines and watches everybody else
get a house well you need a good real
estate agent not going to tell you most
real estate agents aren't good most
people that work at anything aren't that
good at it
still 80/20 principle 80% of the people
make 20% of the money 20% of people make
80% of the money in a business in a
given space that you're in that's always
true there's always the cream of the
crop the top layer of the best of the
best and if you're gonna sell or buy
when it's probably one of your largest
transactions of your life you probably
ought to have a pro in your corner hell
I got my real estate license at 18 years
old in 1978 I've been telling people
this exact thing since then and I'm 58
getting ready to be so god I've had a
real-estate license what is it 30 or 40
years and coming up on unbelievable Wow
but I'll tell you this all the data
points tell us all the research tell us
that when you goof up on your largest
transaction you goof up with zeroes on
the end it costs you thousands and
thousands of dollars I mean you you
don't pull your own teeth or remove your
own kidney I've got an appendix problem
I think I'm gonna get the pocket knife
out you don't do that well you get an
expert involved you get an expert
involved when you're doing your taxes
you get an expert involved when you're
doing your estate planning you get an
expert involved when you're doing your
insurance when you're selling a house
it's no different it's not DIY I've got
a new Corvette I can probably work on
that car but it would be pretty dumb it
would take me twice as long and if I
turn the wrong bolt it could get really
expensive on that expensive car some
things you just don't do I why okay it
doesn't it's paints what they call a
Pennywise and pound-foolish you're
stepping over dollars to pick up nickels
and that's what happens so check out our
endorse local providers when you get
ready to buy you get ready to sell they
actually know what they're doing we
don't have anybody that we endorse that
it's not one of the top realtors in
their area high octane high protein
performers they sell 10 20 30 times as
many houses as their competitors do know
get somebody list in your house it sells
two houses a year so my list is your
house sells two houses a week that's
what you want my notes what they're
doing real estate it's too big a deal
yeah there's a lot of pressure around
this subject it's a good subject to
learn more about
this is the kind of stuff we teach in
Financial Peace University in other
places about real estate
check our endorse local providers
they'll help you at Dave Ramsey comm
find a high-octane realtor in your area
this is the Dave Ramsey show